Christian ich hoffe dass du nicht mit
dieser ganzen Geschichte einfach so
davon kommst wenn doch dann wäre es halt
sehr traurig
Helge B ist der einzige Zeuge und er sie
sicher Christian Brückner hat die kleine
Maddie vor 16 Jahren entführt
schaut man sich die jüngsten
Entwicklungen im Fall Maddie McCann an
dann fällt auf dass alles auf einen Mann
hinausläuft den Zeugen Helge B er ist
derjenige der hat und BKA auf die Spur
des Verdächtigen Christian Brückner
gebracht hat er ist auch derjenige der
mit seiner Aussage dafür gesorgt hat
dass Christian Brückner heute in Haft
sitzt
mehrere Jahre hat sich dieser Zeuge in
Südafrika versteckt wollte nicht mit der
Presse sprechen mir ist es jetzt
gelungen ihn zu überreden mir Interview
zu geben
[Musik]
LG 52 Jahre alt hat sich noch nie
öffentlich geäußert seit Jahren stimmt
in das BKA ab bis jetzt Welt exklusiv
trifft Bild den hauptzollen im Fall mehr
die meckern der Ort muss geheim bleiben
zum allerersten Mal berichtet Helge
dabei öffentlich wie ein Brückner
kennengelernt hat und wie sich Brückner
angeblich verraten haben soll die
Geschichte ist ebenso skurril wie
schockierend
Helge B und Christian Brückner verkehren
damals in denselben Kleinkriminellen
Kreisen als Brückner eine Haftstrafe
verbüßt steigt Helge B in dessen
leerstehendes Haus in Portugal ein steht
eine Waffe und eine Videokamera mit
Kassetten
habe ich dann ersten zwei drei Videos
gesehen und gedacht ach scheiße und
touristenscheiß habe ich so gedacht ne
ja bis ich dann noch das Video gestoßen
bin
in der älteren Dame die da
schwer misshandelt worden ist also da
muss ich da muss ich da jetzt gar nicht
was das ist
ob das jetzt nur so ein Film ist oder so
habe ich erst gesagt das ist irgendwie
ein Film
und dann hatte ich ja schon mal gehört
dass es solche Sachen Videos gibt es
existiert ja auch sowas ne
vielleicht ist das sowas ne
ja und dann habe ich das geguckt und
hat danach gesehen dass Christian ist
und da war mir dann klar irgendwie nee
das ist hier kein knapp video
das ist der da
eine Frau vergewaltigt hat ja was war da
konkret zu sehen
ja wir die Frau misshandelt hat also
ausgepeitscht hat
die Frau hatte da eine Taucherbrille
auf gehabt mit
grau angemalt dass man da nicht
durchgucken konnte
sie war gefesselt
[Musik]
nicht zur Polizei zu gehen er will sich
nicht selbst belasten meidet aber
Brückner ab diesem Moment erst ein Jahr
später treffen die Männer erneut
aufeinander zufällig auf eine
Musikfestival ja und dann hat der
mich dann irgendwann mal gefragt ja
fährst du nicht mehr nach Portugal du
machst da business
sorry sollte das Mädchen da verschwunden
ist ähm
Portugal weil da sind einfach zu viele
Polizei Kontrollen und
das braucht man ja gar nicht ne
irgendwie ne und
da habe ich gesagt das verstehe ich
sowieso nicht wie die kleine da äh so
spurlos verschwinden kann ja irgendwie
sind wir dann auf die gekommen auf
Maddie ja
und
[Musik]
daraufhin hat der Christian
da einen rausgehen die hat ja auch schon
zwei drei Bier getrunken das will ich
jetzt nicht wie ihn als Entschuldigung
gelten lassen ja aber daraufhin hat er
dann gesagt ja die hat ja nicht
geschrieben
und ich habe das aber in dem Augenblick
gecheckt was er da gesagt hat ich war
bei klarem sinn und verstand was hat er
gesagt hat ja
jetzt kenne ich seine Vorgeschichte
ja was ich auf den Videos gesehen habe
und dann haut dir hier so einen raus
hol mir dann ganz elend da ja wo mir
dann echt richtig Elend war ja
zum ersten Mal spricht Helge Baby
öffentlich über dieses Erlebnis der eine
Satz wird in sein Leben lang begleiten
die hat ja nicht geschrieben
behauptet er habe daraufhin die Polizei
informiert und das viel früher als
bisher bekannt so ich habe 2018
England unter der Hotline
und ja man hat meine Personalien damals
aufgenommen ja meine Telefonnummer und
ich habe gesagt ja dass ich da jemanden
kenne der da wohl mit was zu tun hat ja
und habe dem Scottland ja auch den Namen
gegeben von diesem Herrn
aber
da ist halt nichts passiert
da ist nichts passiert man hat mich nie
wieder zurückgerufen
und man hat auch nie den Herrn Brückner
daraufhin festgenommen
und ich habe dann das einfach erstmal
sacken lassen weil ich gedacht habe die
werden sich schon drum kümmern aber
passiert ist am Ende da gar nichts
2008 also wir hiergebe die Polizei zum
ersten Mal informiert haben sollte Scott
und ja tatsächlich zehn Jahre früher
eine Spur zu Brückler gehabt haben ohne
ihr nachzugehen
erst 2017 bei einer 10 Jahre später
wendet sich Helge be erneut an die
Polizei also diese Kontaktaufnahme kam
nach meiner Entlassung in
Lamia habe ich dann dann gewohnt
das ist auch ein griechischen Festland
dort habe ich dann gewohnt und diese
Kontaktaufnahme kamen dann
als ich
als ich gehört habe von dem zehnjährigen
Jubiläum
im ich weiß nicht mehr ich glaube ich
habe das auf Youtube geguckt ist ja
eigentlich ein trauriges Jubiläum aber
das war dann halt das zehnjährige
Jubiläum
was mir dann wieder das in den Kopf
gebracht hat also damals mein Anruf
2008 hatte einen kleinen gar nichts
genutzt ja
und ich war aber schon entlassen
und habe dann außer also von
Griechenland aus das wird noch mals ja
doch dieses Mal geht's Gott im Hinweis
nach es kommt zu einem Treffen zu
Ermittlung und schließlich zum Prozent
helgebe ist Zeuge aufgrund seiner
Aussage wird Christian Brückner zu 7
Jahren Haft verurteilt für Helge B der
Beginn eines ganz persönlichen Dramas
also ich habe nicht damit gerechnet
welche Dimensionen das überhaupt annimmt
das war mir eigentlich nicht so klar
und ich glaube ich würde es heute nicht
noch einmal machen ich würde das heute
wenn ich sowas glaube ich wüsste ich
würde es nicht noch mal machen
weil es hat ja mein Leben auch ruiniert
ja ich war eigentlich da wo ich war sehr
glücklich gewesen
ich hatte meine Arbeit ich hatte keine
Sorgen
zumindest finanziell nicht
und das war dann auch einmal alles weg
ja wie ist das warum war das plötzlich
einmal auf einmal alles weg ja
irgendwelche Leute bei mir vor der Tür
gestanden haben
weil Leute bei mir auf der Arbeit waren
und es wusste ja keine auch da Arbeit
nachher haben das dann meine Nachbarn
mitbekommen
die dann natürlich auch nicht gut auf
mich zu sprechen sind ja was wieso kennt
ihr diejenige so einen Typen ja
das frage ich mich dann heute manchmal
auch noch
wenn dann kann ich das jetzt noch mal
nicht mehr das heißt sie ihre
Vergangenheit eingeholt die größte
Fehler meines Lebens
Videos mitgenommen habe
am liebsten hätte ich mir gewünscht ich
hätte davon nichts gewusst ja auf der
anderen Seite auf der anderen Seite
haben Sie damit möglicherweise wer weiß
es noch nicht ganz absehbar aber
möglicherweise zur Auflösung eines der
spektakulärsten Kriminalfälle der Welt
beigetragen also sie sind derjenige der
das ausgelöst hat
ja stolz bin ich nicht drauf
selbst wenn es mal Verurteilung kommen
sollte
doch Helge B ist sich nach wie vor
sicher Christian Brückner hat die kleine
Mandy entführt
also das ist jetzt meine Theorie
meine
dann werde das kann das ja den Christian
jetzt nicht
unterstellen der ist ja in der Hinsicht
noch unschuldig
meine Theorie ist
das ein Einbruch
und
das halt irgendwie schief gegangen ist
und er die Kinder
das ist meine Theorie
das war wahrscheinlich gar nicht geplant
darum gehe ich mal stark aus dass es
nicht geplant war
es war halt ein Zufall
sie kennen sie kannten ihn ja
sie haben diese Videos gesehen
trauen sie so eine Tat zu so eine
Zufallszahl ja also so eine Tat würde
ich ihm auf jeden Fall zutrauen nachdem
ich nach dem jetzt was ich alles über
ihn weiß
kann ich Ihnen
für Helge B ist klar Maddie McCann ist
nicht mehr am Leben an die
Öffentlichkeit wendet er sich nun weil
er sein Leben zurück haben möchte von
einer Belohnung will er nichts wissen
Geld will er nie genommen haben noch
einmal auf ihr Gefühlsleben zurückkommen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie es
sich anfühlt der wichtigste Zeuge in
einem der bekanntesten Kriminalfälle der
Welt zu sein
wie fühlt sich das an
schlecht
also ich fühle mich nicht gut mir geht's
nicht gut
hat meine Gesundheit beeinträchtigt
ich habe zugenommen
ich habe Mama meine Phasen wo ich an
durchdrehen bin ich habe Hasen wo ich
Nächte lang nicht schlafe
also es ist kein schönes Gefühl ich
glaube mit mir möchte da auch wohl
keiner tauschen und immer so eine Art
auf der Flucht zu sein das ist richtig
kein richtiges zu Hause
immer auf alles aufpassen wie man was
sagt
wenn man was erzählt
ja
also unsere Freunde Familie
Freunde habe ich keine mehr
e
aber Freunde wahre Freunde habe ich
nicht mehr
mein letzter Freund ist im Oktober
gestorben auf große ich auch nicht
durfte nicht mal zu Beerdigung
also so traurig sieht mein Leben aus ja
am Ende des Interviews hat Helge B noch
ein Anliegen er möchte sich direkt an
den Verdächtigen wenden Christian ich
hoffe dass du nicht mit dieser ganzen
Geschichte einfach so davon kommst wenn
doch dann wäre es halt sehr traurig
und glaubt nicht
dass du denkst dass ich die Videos nicht
gesehen habe
du leugnest ist dass es diese Videos
nicht gibt aber diese Videos hat es
gegeben und ich habe sie gesehen und das
kannst du mir glauben